[Music]
who here has dealt with imposter
syndrome yeah we got this question from
uh some of our viewers because i think
like you know this is very common these
days where a lot of people feel like oh
[ __ ] man i got the imposter syndrome or
like i'm afraid of getting it or like
described as doubting your abilities and
feeling like a fraud yeah it
disproportionately affects
high achieving people who find it
difficult to accept their
accomplishments
and um i would say that we're all
pretty high achieving like we all
kind of done stuff
that um others would find
accomplishing
and many question whether they deserve
they're deserving of their accolades
meaning like do you even deserve where
you are today
yeah i felt like i probably dealt with
it up until maybe even like last year i
feel like maybe two years ago because
you didn't feel like you were an
official fitness guru until graham
stefan called you one yeah it was graham
stefan who called you a fitness guru
nobody else called you a fitness guru
before that yeah only graham stefan yep
check out those butt cheeks too i love
how gram stefan didn't even know about
jk and they just basically says
bodybuilder spent x money
and everyone's like he's jk
i i did try to warn him but he would not
heed my advice um
yeah oh you oh yeah but you know what i
was like bart you are a [ __ ] fitness
guru on instagram it's what you put out
there it's what everyone sees
but you know what
half of the comments were jk fans going
like bart finally got his wish of being
a fitness guru
no but even starting when like uh i
would say maybe even junior high high
school days
where like uh
when we're like doing like gang like
activities okay like gang like you know
not gay not actual gang stuff but gang
like activities
and then i would like our crew would go
around like banging and stuff and i
would just see the other ones on the
news
and it felt like oh man we weren't
hardcore enough or whatever especially
like growing up like in cerritos right
and that's tough and then when i came
here
when i met real gangsters i was like oh
[ __ ] this is
i think that's when like i was like uh
that's not not really me and then um
you're like i'm pretend gang gaming yeah
cause like imposter syndrome a gang
member like it did feel like this
pressure of like it sounds funny because
it sounds so ridiculous but it's crazy
when you're like in it right and you're
like okay so we've been in the fights
but i never really blasted anyone in the
face i never really like you know like
uh like tie the whole family up and
[ __ ]
and burglarize the house and there's
still time dude
you still do come on dude
the heights is still there but when
you're laughing when you're like 13 or
14 in that mindset like i think even
back then i don't know if that's to do
with asian like parent upbringing or
whatever you're not good enough you just
feel like even your gangsterism wasn't
good like those ones are [ __ ] way
harder dude what are we doing [ __ ]
cinnamon i know you ran for a helicopter
not once you're like i only sold
an ounce of weed
when is it gonna be a pound of weed yeah
like who am i gonna go to jail dude yeah
that makes sense though i think
everybody goes through imposters i guess
that's kind of the upside of imposter
syndrome
what's the upside it saved you from
going full gangster it saved you from
shooting somebody in the face
now he said blasting blasting in the
face
but then like going on to college right
like i go to community college and then
i transfer and when you go there then
they're like oh you transferred oh and
you're like oh yeah that's dreading
getting out of high school like the real
people did you know yeah i just feel
like you deal with this you're imposter
brewing i think you're supposed to deal
with it though really cause i i think
well to a certain degree i think it's on
a spectrum for everybody right
you could have imposter center to the
point where you don't do [ __ ]
anything right where you're afraid to
like take that first step but i think
for some people you need to be thinking
about like am i doing what i need to do
am i doing the right things am i pushing
myself hard enough in certain aspects of
whatever your life is you know like for
me like uh when i first started like
coaching people i had imposter syndrome
about coaching i was like
you know i don't think i could coach
people like who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] am
i but you have the actual credentials
though yeah but at the time when you
tell yourself right yeah what you tell
yourself is like why do people want to
listen to me yada yada but you know i
think how you kind of escape imposter
syndrome is just doing the work that's
like having an md and like why do people
come to me when they're sick
like you have the actual credentials
yeah i think that's what imposter
syndrome is you have you have the
credential yeah because the opposite of
that i think is what i had which is
delusion
[Laughter]
which is kind of fire though come to me
when there's things you still do don't
worry i think you still sometimes i
think i wish i need i had more
entitlement
um
we call it when you don't have the
credentials but you believe you can do
better than everybody else
arrogant a high level arrogance air
against an ego yeah
that's what i had i mean isn't it
imposter syndrome in essence just like a
almost like a subsidiary of like the
grander ego concept like whether it be
like self-awareness or just your
arrogance even like everybody does kind
of almost like a child right you kind of
have to like
explore the curiosity of your own ego in
order to understand where is either too
far or where you feel comfortable but
impostor is just i guess the not enough
part of it right and you kind of dwell
on it and you feel bad about yourself my
biggest imposter syndrome i feel like
comes every single time i visit my
parents it's like hey how are you doing
oh yeah killing is still doing good blah
blah blah right and it's not necessarily
like a lie but it's like also like you
always put a different type of uh
maybe a spin on it yeah just the way you
articulate it and then i'll be you know
sometimes leaving and thinking to myself
like is that really how things are right
now i'm not really that good is
everything gonna actually be okay yeah
that's true that that's that's i think
that's very specific to parents right
like yeah those don't wanna worry your
parents either that's a big part of it
too right you don't want to worry
anybody you want to you want to leave
them alone and make it right feel good
you don't want to tell them what's
really going on
in every detail especially to your
parents and you're older now you know so
it is a different like kind of way like
i think your parents expect you to be in
some type of way at a certain age you
know so in your mind you're probably in
your own head like i don't want to like
maybe disappoint them because maybe
that's where the feeling comes from
that's you're trying to be the kid that
you think that they want you to be yeah
is that like a part of a possibility of
imposter i think there's an aspect of
that for sure i think i think a big part
of it is also comparing
yeah comparing like because when you get
good at something you you're always in
full view and you can also see the
person that's better and that's it's
hard to [ __ ] put blinders on when
you're doing anything you're like oh i
know a million people who are better
than me at the thing i want to do so
it's like so then why should i even do
it that's why some people who are
delusional are [ __ ] amazing because
they don't think anybody's better than
them and then they just
swore dude incredible but like you've
been athletes right you see this all the
time where you're like oh i could i
could win the championship or whatever
the [ __ ] and you know exactly like
i don't think so as a fan but that's
what they have to tell themselves to
show up every day to put in the work in
before they can you know get that
championship that they're looking for
it's like when you watch any weigh-in
you know you like they're both 100
confident but you already know one of
them to get their ass beat there's like
[ __ ] seven over but it doesn't mean
he had an imposter syndrome he's like no
he's doing what he has to do exactly in
order to win sometimes that is how you
win
but then i already know the [ __ ] cure
to imposter syndrome what is it like if
i was a psychiatrist and i had to tell
someone they had it i'd go yeah i'm
diagnosing you with imposter syndrome
which uh
is a side effect of what happens when
you accomplish something so congrats
whoa that made me feel better already
yeah wow no i'll be like i didn't blast
him in the face i told you
you don't want to accomplish that i
didn't run from helicopters what part of
that don't try
but cops don't want to chase me dude
joe's like of course i don't have a
positive i'm delusional
it's like of course i i achieved it
that's not the thing i have i think i
think it is it's a good sign i think
it's a good time if you're struggling
with it that means there's at least
something on the table you're at least
self-aware at somewhat thank god right
yeah cause otherwise you're in
delusional land i'm assuming that
there's probably a correlation between
um people that have ocd and um imposter
syndrome because
when you have ocd you have a heightened
sense of
uh you think you're responsible for
things that are unrelated right so
you're very very uh responsible you
might just like over analyze something
go like raid way too deep in the rabbit
hole and believe like you can somehow
cause something that's super big so you
have this slippery slope mindset
and then so if you think that oh maybe
one day
i might be exposed as a fraud and just
sitting all day thinking about like oh
am i even good enough to like be doing
this stuff i think it it might be a
trait of uh or there's some some kind of
cut like i don't know i kind of see like
a trait of those two being related look
everybody [ __ ] up at something right so
so then if you know that you [ __ ] up
with something you know you don't have a
perfect record then you know that you're
capable of [ __ ] up again so when
you're doing something even well
you can always see like over the
mountain maybe okay there's some danger
lurking like maybe i'm gonna [ __ ] this
up you just don't know right but yeah
but if you don't if but if you if you're
constantly thinking about how you're
going to [ __ ] it up you will yeah so
this is such a balance for me maybe it's
not it's also not so much imposter
syndrome but like when you gain a new
identity like
growing up i always wanted to be known
as a dancer like i just want people to
[ __ ] know me as that yeah and then
when you finally attain that the fear of
it getting taken away is pretty [ __ ]
big if you really think about it you're
like damn what if it just gets stripped
and people are like man i thought you
were dead but you just [ __ ] you're
not dancing yeah like that's hard you
know like yeah i'll think about that but
i saw a video you weren't dancing
not one dance move
not one yeah it's like
it's like a thing
because you know like like everyone
growing up it goes through identity
crisis and then once you finally reach
an identity you're happy with
you want to hold on to that you know
yeah i get it
that's so good now i just want to make a
anime reaction video where i watch your
dances i'm like see that's not a move
where's the groove
we should critique his dancing
non-dancers critiqua dancers dancers
so i guess if jumping on your head is a
dance move then i guess the jackass
movies are dance movies
dude [ __ ] crazy dancers live
today's video is brought to you by baby
like many people i try to learn a
language in high school in college and
even tried like flash cards i even tried
back uh buy one little cd-rom things and
then put it in my car but all of that
stuff is the old style you know like
you're the modern times you gotta learn
things fast the modern way which is why
i love babble because they got classes
in short 15 minute segments it's pretty
awesome too because they're super
popular and they sold over 10 million so
far and that means a lot of people know
and trust babel to learn languages from
they have 14 different languages that
you could choose from too spanish
italian german it's so cool yeah it is
developed by over a hundred language
experts to find out what's the best way
to learn it's also a i base so it's
extremely smart got speech recognition
technology to help you with enunciation
they really thought of the whole thing
so much to the point that they have a
20-day money-back guarantee where you
could try it for almost three weeks and
you're like you know what i'm not really
learning the way that i want to learn
you can get your money back and it's a
really fun interactive way like bart
mentioned it's only 15 minutes really
really quick so you could do this every
single day and the way that lessons go
they're interactive and they're very
mentally stimulating so i enjoy it right
now you can save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
off the record that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot
com slash off the record for up to 60
off your subscription that's a crazy
good deal you gotta go there man babble
language for life what's it what's the
difference between i mean obviously
there's a difference between um but like
uh imposter syndrome versus like i guess
is it related to like insecurity then i
think it's a huge insecurity i think it
was all entertainment yeah anything
where you question double like have to
question yourself and think maybe
they'll oust me as a fraud when you're
not fraud fraudulent at all
it's like how do you trick your mind
into believing like oh wait what if i
don't know everything and then the
information that i'm giving out there as
an authority
i miss something and then now i'm giving
misinformation like how do you trick
your own mind to believe that that's
pretty wild to me
or you know sometimes when you're in a
place of influence or like for example
like we'll we'll teach you know i mean
in dance like we'll go out and we'll
like teach sometimes sometimes it's
actually easier to like give a third
party advice than to take your own
advice right somebody might ask you as
artists or creative like oh how do you
like get by creative block or like how
do you do this how do you do that and
when you're given the advice especially
in educational seat it's easy be like oh
you know like this is what you do is
what you do but then when you're in your
own session and you run into that same
block
it's not so simple to take your own
advice and like that can lead to
potentially like you're a hypocrite oh
like a never-ending cycle because i know
i have that for sure for sure
i think everybody struggles with that
you know when you're alone with your own
idea
it's very uh
very
vulnerable yeah you know what i mean
whereas when you could be with somebody
else with their idea then you're not
vulnerable you could just yeah that's
true help them mold and shape their idea
but it's not yours
and it's like hard to look at your own
flaws or things you need to fix
um but it's easier when you're
critiquing other people
you can zoom out i think it's a bigger
problem than it than it is also because
people tend to weaponize
it against other people like they want
you to have imposter syndrome because
they want to bring you down because like
even as a dancer like dancers do that to
each other all the [ __ ] time yeah
they're like man that ain't dancing that
ain't crumping that ain't popping that
ain't logan and all day [ __ ] long
they just say like that's not what it is
to make you
feel like vulnerable to that like oh
maybe i'm not the thing i devoted 10
[ __ ] years to doing you know like who
knows but it's that's also a big problem
is that people use it against each other
all the [ __ ] time like it's not just
an internal battle yeah that shit's
external too but don't make you second
guess yourself when you're watching
anything aren't you like you know kind
of you can you can choose to [ __ ] on it
or love it at the same time and
sometimes if you're in a good mood
you're gonna [ __ ] on it because if
you're a bad mood you're showing it yeah
your headspace is always all is like
incumbent on how you're going to react
do you guys feel like imposter syndrome
is a phrase or something that you've
been hearing a little more recently in
the past like [ __ ] i've never heard
of it my whole life so part of me feels
like oh it's probably exacerbated by
social media right because i think it's
a feeling that you've always had yeah
you don't know the word and it's
clinically named now i guess i guess i
think
yeah you're right with the social media
because we're so much [ __ ] go viral so
quick so that anything that's met with
fast success is like you'll start to
double guess like wait do i deserve all
this [ __ ] because um i was talking to um
oh uh stephanie sue uh when we were on a
[ __ ] genius brain together and then
she was talking about how she was
dealing with imposter syndrome and i'm
like girl you eat food and tell stories
on camera like what do you mean you
don't deserve to be there if people like
your personality it's not like you're
[ __ ]
the best basketballer in the world and
it took you so many years to do that and
you got to pass up you just you're just
who you are and you created a whole
thing behind it you created a format
that's
like how can you be an imposter of what
you create what does she think she was
like imposterizing order well i can
understand what the social media tip too
that nick's talking about as well like
um if i'm having a bad day i'm not not
the type of person necessarily to post
on social media about my bad day
therefore most people who look not very
transparent
yeah you're a friend you're making me
insecure right now
[Laughter]
actually you're bullying as an imposter
because you off camera you love me nah
that's true this is a fake front bro i
can confirm that that's not true
bart actually hates you off-camera but
you know what i'm saying it's like
everybody for like a long time you end
up especially if you have like hundreds
of thousands or millions of followers
like in order to get there a lot of
people aren't overly transparent with
the reality of their lives and their
situation so i can assume that
yeah in today's generation and when
you're building a brand too it's like
you got to do things that are for your
brand so like opening up about like your
day necessarily is not part of what you
do to like maybe bring joy to others
like ninjas are [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] talking about the day all the
time
let's bring it back to junebe or
something
i mean
jimmy's pretty cool though is this real
matcha [ __ ] imposter it is
it's actually from the mountains of
japan okay let's take it back to barbell
then yeah yeah yeah so the other the
next phase of imposter that i felt
brigade the next
uh the next phase of imposter that i
felt was when i was in the military
which like i never deployed right but
that's not even my choice like the
government chooses units you'd have to
deploy it you weren't in the military
that's why i never really share stories
or i don't think like that's something i
don't even feel like i'm part of the
community even though i served
i went to a boot camp
i've been to north carolina camp lejeune
i've been at camp pendleton
now he's just bragging
it's ridiculous but i've never been here
i still don't feel like i really served
just because i didn't deploy even though
it's not even
my choice you know what i mean right so
for people that don't know the military
that means like the government chooses
which units are activated and every
every group is in a unit right yeah and
you also have active military and you
have reserve and you you're in the
reserve so that means you weren't like
living on bases and all this stuff and
making that wasn't your career well my
unit went to iraq three times already so
in that that span they already maxed out
so how come you didn't go with them is
it because you joined after they came
back i joined yeah i joined after so
when they attached me to that unit um i
actually signed up and then they're like
no this unit isn't gonna go anymore for
the next uh i don't know how long the
term was before it start starts the
rotation again you bummed out is that
when you went
in the book no i signed up and then when
i came back
i came back and told my mom and my dad
they're like are you [ __ ] stupid we
only have you
and i was like oh yeah that's true but
you know when you're like 18 you're just
so [ __ ] gung-ho you want to do
everything yeah yeah so would you just
be like no don't worry i'm a supply guy
but you still get bombed and [ __ ] that's
true they they're the ones that actually
got shot up blown up the most if you're
the radar guy you're good though the
radar guys always get support the guy
the guy with the phone the radio guy the
guy who's always like where is everybody
where the hell are you
[Laughter]
we need backing we need air support oh
then you hear boom and then you see the
phone yeah
he's like there's no one coming there's
no one
radio operators they
they're on the front lines all the time
it's they're tough yeah they're the guys
that get blown up and someone else has
to pick up the phone and [ __ ]
yeah no that's not me i'm not dennis
nope kevin yeah no no you can't come to
the phone you gotta stuff your nose you
have a cold yeah i got kind of cold
yeah so even with that i felt like
um
that i don't feel like i'm really in the
community you know even though i am but
it just it just never felt that way but
it wasn't until like maybe even
a year or two years ago where i was like
man life is just life dude you just do
things yeah and there's no and
everyone's perspective is [ __ ]
different like i talk to my buddies that
aren't like special operations they're
like dude you served and that's your
part of i'm like oh thanks man that's so
cool you know it just feels like it's
just just part of life yeah yeah dude i
feel this way because i was like
you know tuber trooper boy and i do a
movie
and [ __ ] and like dude there are people
who live in la
now who've been there my whole time i've
been alive who've never been in a
[ __ ] movie i got to do a movie like
right away and the fact that like i
gotta afford that opportunity and i
wasn't really an actor like not really a
[ __ ] actor like i didn't spend a lot
of time in acting classes like grinding
doing all the [ __ ] that these guys do
like which i respect so much yeah like
you guys know because i had you guys go
to that lady and she's like [ __ ]
amazing and like even i'm like like who
i've been in the movie and i'm like i
can't believe how hard acting is you
know what i mean like real acting yeah
real acting so it's like you know but i
was in a comedy movie but still i just
there's a part of me that definitely
feels bad because somebody else out
there never got that opportunity and for
me it wasn't even like necessarily what
i was going for the times just something
happened
that was like okay cool like i'm just
trying to be which is life right yeah
yeah yeah but you do feel that way you
do feel like that little bit of guilt
sometimes well would you argue that you
might think that it just happened but in
reality you know that it's like you had
something to offer like everything that
you had done in your life had brought
you to that moment of opportunity yeah
maybe i mean you could have also
squandered it too because i've seen so
many times like we've all seen people
who
get opportunities and then they [ __ ] it
up completely yeah you never know you
never know i mean because it's not like
i sit here and go well yeah and i want
an oscar yeah
i mean it's just one of those things
where
you you don't love everything that you
did either
so you because of all that too you're
not
i'm not sitting here beating my dick to
hood or anything yeah it's really good i
feel like a part of imposter syndrome
also comes from just being hard on
yourself too yeah yeah you know you're
just like did i actually work that hard
or i do whatever and
i think that that's part of it too all
right this has been enough for being
real let's get back to getting funny
after this all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you